charlotte on va voir qui est le meilleur
passeur mais pas du tout pour s assurer
qu attends attends 2006 deux minutes se
plaît tu sais on a enseigné d'amitié
tous les deux il ya un terrain début de
quelque chose
ok c'est bon alors on y va charlotte et
mac si vous mettez sur 7 ces charlatans
c'est charles gimat charlotte et après
sera julie julia côté nous vers la côte
et nos boss vallières a tenté dans sa
relation
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
et
[Musique]
et c'est un génie ce maxime dallaire
elle sortait de chez elle frères ethan
est encore faisant ressortir à qatar
elle est en train de faire une femme
l'oubli avoue frère avec un capteur
bonjour soir elle arrive on arrête comme
ça les patois journée mais dis-moi
victimes donc surtout director et maxime
sans rien incroyable non merci
non mais tu attends c'est une caméra
cachée arrêté non mais serais-tu nancy
perdu sa gentille et maxime partenaires
une 8e fait bien dans ses bras mais je
vous jure
non seulement elle se lâcher tout
parfait ah bah écoute maintenant on va
bien voir notre prochain couple elle
aimait porter à danser avec des nippes
ça mais à l'aller comme il est beau
gosse base on perd 0,10 réplique à ce
que je vais dire mais je vais te suivre
je peux te lâcher maintenant
est ce que parce que moi je crois je
crois au destin est ce que tu veux que
je devienne un petit peu ton tour voilà
que je te suivent sur tous les tournois
que voilà que je te que je t'aide à
encore aller plus haut mais clairement
quand j'arrive pas à attaquer la gym
interne on est c'est fait c'est fait
c'est fait écoute moi bien c'est fait je
ne colle pas tu vas tu vas me donner ton
numéro on va devoir après et je verrai
je vais tout faire pour toi parce que je
le sens j'ai le pif et avec une coupe
beaucoup comme ça tu peux pas perdre et
tu veux pas perdre des matches zéro
comme un mal au coeur
l'écueil europe direct dit non il a une
d'écolo c'est pas possible c'est beau ça
ce que tu as fait j'aime bien mais alors
c'est bon alors je sais qu'il n'était
pas dans la danse voilà prêts du tout
l'été avec des frérots elle ferait
danser un arbre se dit
c'est un arbre donc vas-y jules on y va
tu fais ce que tu peux faire et je tombe
amber apaire vas-y encore tenté au tour
de vis à tabasser par voiture
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
ouais
voir et
[Musique]
bon
[Applaudissements]
je pense aux jo
ok
franchement peur
oui oui je reconnais lui c'est comme les
codes italy's non je suis pas sur la mer
tu connais ya toujours un mec comme ça
en soirée tu valoir qu il était sur la
tête fait faillite au nom de nous tous
des fous et une fois qu'il est parti sur
le dossier frère c'est un dossier tout
en une heure jenny toi et tu vas me
donner ton numéro et j'ai la paix est
toujours être merci à jules est démis de
sa magnifique j'ai pas envie j'ai pas
envie de départager charlotte a été
formidable et il a été formidable
maxime a été formidable alors denilson
maxime jacques annaud de ouf pour vous
ah oui ouais je vous le dis les séries
chaque ado de au point puisque je vous
invite à votre spectacle
le 1er juin au théâtre du gymnase et
julie et charlotte de place pour toi de
place pour toi
non tu vas y aller avec une copine ou
avec le petit oui d'accord
jules tagme na waie alors il ya eu il ya
eu le le savez quoi
le silence de se dire est ce que je le
dis des mots qui me voient qu'ils m'ont
qui fait donc il a fait comme ça time à
vue ouais comme la belle lucy lucy
longtemps bras tu vas partir avec jules
voir le spectacle et jules laisse moi
m'occuper de toi je te le demande en
services
mais avec grand plaisir vraiment
franchement jusque là vraiment je veux
bien jouer sa neige de semer c'est sûr
tu vas bien joué cette année sur le toit
bien c'est pas tu vas bien joué cette
année c'est où va bien je statut et à
partir de maintenant ceux qui nous
regardent les federer et nadal et
djokovic
les turcs covic l'aîné les filières lait
nadal a à l'est dominique team à eybens
maintenant je peux vous dire les gars
dominique team for roland garros urac
une team
il se sera jules et moi d'avoir juges tu
va tout péter frérot thème fort merci
merci l'europe